hello there welcome to day two of bang a
week think we should have called it
broom week boo boo powerful bang they're
surprisingly powerful now nothing better
to start your Tuesday morning than a bit
of breakfast what we've got here down in
my lovely sort of flowery bowl we've got
some fruit bran or something a fruit
fiber through the fiber yes one and five
orange juice nice glossy bougie yeah
sip how's it really good
hey let's split up where did the ball go
what's the pool so you know that from
now when your breakfast starts bubbling
you have to run away yeah I like this
spoon clatter the orange juice and the
orange juice spilt on dick guy the
remains of dick guy on his tip ah well
this is part of my childhood this bulb
oh is really yeah whoever's your
childhood Louie uh this is the biggest
piece we could find absolutely a nice
let's just disappear that's not the
fruit fiber I got this integrate as well
oh well successful day all us on Twitter
tune back in tomorrow excellent sword